as an entrepreneur as a group of
entrepreneurs anything that you give out
will 100 value here and any mistake you
make in the beginning will you're going
to be the one that's going to be paying
for that mistake so it's very important
especially in the beginning and
especially when you're dealing with
Equity to be very careful and make sure
that things are very very clear welcome
to 20 minute leaders just sit back relax
and learn from the leaders of today it's
a journey each one is different unique
inspiring let's get started
[Music]
20-minute leaders is a proud supporter
of Make-a-Wish Israel and Tech to peace
and is in proud collaboration with
secret Court Ventures J Ventures
Riverside fam Fusion VC Birthright Excel
J impact leap Google for startups and
hippo and in media partnership with ctec
foreign
welcome to 20 minute leaders today I'm
being joined by Ellie sprung a partner
at igalanon tadmolevy law offices with a
special expertise in the field of
high-tech and Venture Capital his
clients include high-tech companies and
entrepreneurs as well as Venture Capital
funds incubators and accelerators in a
wide array of Industries Ellie has
extensive experience in representing his
clients in financing exit transactions
intellectual property and Commercial
transactions and agreements as well as
assisting in the day-to-day operations
of a company with his practice spanning
the entire life cycle of emerging growth
companies
[Music]
Ellie sprung welcome to 20 minute
leaders how are you
I'm great Michael thanks for having me
I'm excited to get to know you better
over these 20 minutes Ellie has you've
been a part of the the ecosystem the
tech ecosystem for quite some time but
not just from the tech sector uh with
Todd Mor levian Co and you know
high-tech and VC partner and you're
getting to work both with entrepreneurs
with with investors sites throughout
different life cycles all across from
the early stages to M A's Etc and so I'm
looking forward to picking your brain on
these different stages the different
experiences you've had with these
different stakeholders both from a
personal level on your on your own
experiences but also insights that
you've garnered over these years as to
the do's and don'ts and potential
potentially give us some tips on on
things that you know is young
entrepreneur can can work on avoiding so
Ellie let's get started tell me a little
bit about your your own Journey what
brought you into this ecosystem and how
did you end up here
well I take the path started I wasn't
when I was in the Army I was in the IDF
spokesperson's unit and I was finishing
up and I knew I wanted to go to
university but wasn't really sure what I
wanted to do uh so I took back then way
back then it was there was a book you
didn't have to apply online
um and I looked for everything to see
what was interesting and the law was the
most
was the least of all evils to go into
that didn't sound the most boring so I
said that sounds like something good and
then so I applied to law and thankfully
I also got in and I started going to law
and then uh when we needed I needed to
find an internship so I I interviewed at
egalarnon where I started my internship
and really because of my English and my
Hebrew because that was such an asset I
saw that the high-tech world is really a
place where I could put that asset to
use
um that's kind of where it started and I
dated business and Tech World always
interested me so it was kind of The
Perfect Storm and I started there and uh
found it to actually be interesting and
really piqued my interest and enjoyed it
so
and and I've been enjoying it ever since
I'd say for unfortunately unfortunately
it's been more than 20 years now so uh
it's still made it been interesting and
then to
go back to my roots in the end when egal
are known and I became a partner at
toddler Levy and then when both firms
merged so now it's Levy I went back to
my roots so now I'm back to where I
started and uh everything's back to
normal quote unquote
what do you think about your your
position the the way that you're
interacting with the ecosystem made you
do it for so long you know what is it
that that you know sort of keeps keeps
you alive in the state
um you know some people say look Ellie
for what you're doing here you're kind
of just a lawyer all you guys have
templates it's the kind of cookie cutter
and you're just doing the same thing
over and over and over again you know
hey how's it interesting and B what you
know why do I have to pay so much money
for you to do nothing really
um but I think the peaking of the
interest is there's a lot that's the
same there's also a lot that's different
and there's a lot that really depends on
the founders um entrepreneurs on their
business and how they see the business
on on the market Etc and each one has
its little idiosyncrasies and at the end
the tech is really cool
um and that always keeps things
interesting
um every deal has its own little
special special thing
um you know you go up against Council
that you've done many deals together
before and each one has its own issues
it's all its own things that you really
need to work on
um I also find the people I just think
the holiday Tech and each person has
their own you know you make a lot of
friends over life
and thankfully I think most of my
clients I can call not only clients but
also friends
very very cool tell me a little bit
about you know the way that you're
seeing no the the entrepreneurial
Journey from your side of things right
so you get to experience entrepreneurs
and stakeholders in different parts
along their along their Cycles you know
how do you experience the the startup
mindset from your end
so I think a lot of times you see I want
to say kids which is kind of insulting
but unfortunately as you can see the the
amount of hair that I have on my head or
or that I don't have in my head that uh
I'm usually a little bit older than most
of the entrepreneurs
but um you know so these people come in
you thought Brewers come in and and
they're literal Geniuses
their tech knowledge and their computer
knowledge and programming knowledge and
and Engineering knowledge Etc is is
really off the charts but sometimes just
you know having done and and been with a
lot of startups hundreds if not
thousands of startups and seen them on
their Journey so there's a lot even
though I don't have that
genius in Tech genius in
um in the engineering and stuff like
that we could still help them a lot but
not only in the legal World
um there was one entrepreneur that came
in and told me about her product and uh
she told me about this issue she had and
in the end uh we proposed a proposal
that that could really help her with her
product and I think in the end that that
Authority actually didn't end up hiring
us as as her lawyers but um you know it
was I thought it was a great idea for
the product and I think she actually
used it for her product
um so you know because we've seen a lot
we can help it and I think we're trusted
advisors not only on the legal side but
really also also and everything else
that that comes along a lot of times
we'll give business advice and different
uh tips for entrepreneurs along the way
that can that really can help for
instance if he's an entrepreneur that is
isn't a developer and needs development
help
um and will Outsource it which I which
happens sometimes so they'll say okay
and you know they've reached an
agreement between the entrepreneur and
the developer that for let's just say
fifty thousand dollars the person will
develop the app or whatever it is so the
person tells me and said okay I'm gonna
give him fifty thousand dollars but you
know I'll come back and say okay fifty
thousand dollars is great can you wait
till the end for fifty thousand dollars
when you're happy with the product Oh
that's a great idea I was just gonna
give him fifty five thousand dollars up
front and then you have a little bit of
negotiation because the developer
doesn't want to get everything at the
end so if you can Milestone base it or
little things like that that someone who
doesn't have the experience in doing
deals with other people that's really
things I think as a trusted advisor you
can really help these entrepreneurs who
again are geniuses on the one side but
total novices on the other side and
that's really where I think it's
important to get a a good lawyer who
knows what he or she is doing and also
has done it many times can really come
and help so
you know it's a good segue to some of
the considerations of perhaps the
do's and don'ts that are that are not
necessarily the most trivial for young
entrepreneurs maybe the things that we
don't necessarily read and read in the
playbooks the things that you've
experienced in your own in your own
State what are what are some key
key Concepts just like the example that
you mentioned with the Outsourcing
dilemma what what are some of these
situations that you've experienced that
now as you're working with with young
entrepreneurs you're saying okay these
are things that I've especially on the
lookout for because I know that with the
lack of experience the more opted to to
make a mistake
I think the most there are two important
things that an entrepreneur has the most
important is obviously the IP that the
entrepreneur is developing because
that's in the end of the day if you're
hoping to be acquired that's what the
acquirer is interested in so you need to
do whatever you can do to make sure your
IP is protected whether that's an MBA
whether that's an assignment agreement
you want to make sure if anyone's doing
any development work for you that that
person says whatever I do for you
belongs to you it does sound trivial it
does sound trivial but many times you
know I we've been in situations where
that piece of paper wasn't signed and
that person then came back and said oh
no I'm one of the founders and I I get
you know 30 percent is mine or the IP is
mine I never gave it to you I just gave
you a license and the ownership Still
Remains with me so these police
interactions actually actually happen
when you now when
100 I mean these These are actual these
are real stories these aren't things
that I've just made up these are things
if again if you've been doing this for
20 years you see a lot
you know some for instance one person
once said uh Ellie look here's here's my
company look at this great agreement I
signed this guy said he can bring great
investors because one thing that a
company needs to run is money uh he's
going to create great investors and and
I'm only have to give him five percent
and look here and gave him five percent
and I said that's great what happens if
he doesn't bring you an investor
oh then you've given him five percent
and he's done absolutely nothing
oh yeah well that's a good point you
know and after a German sign it's a
little hard to unwind it but for the
other hand you know and if the agreement
is to give the person five percent
that's great but let that person earn
the five percent so I always say give
equity for for something that person has
done and not not for something that
person didn't do anything so here's a
here's a dilemma I'd like to present to
you a lot of the examples that you've
given me it seems like a shortfall or
shortcoming of the entrepreneur side is
that they're running it quickly towards
the work and towards the what we call in
Hebrew the tough list without
necessarily laying a foundation which
keeps them
which keeps them uh you know yeah
exactly now walk me through why that is
what's happening you know what is
perhaps the reluctancy or the lack of
knowledge from the entrepreneurs that is
causing this problem and why and and
what are ways that we can that that we
as young entrepreneurs can change our
mindset and become better at it
I think I think you've hit it right on
the nose when you said the lack of
knowledge I think entrepreneurs don't
realize the importance of certain things
you know they think that lawyers are
important later on in time and uh you
know they don't realize that sometimes a
short conversation with a lawyer in the
beginning can really save a lot of
Heartache a lot of money and a lot of
strife at the end
we once had a company that they wanted
to incorporate very quickly and they
went on to the Registrar of company site
and they saw that incorporating a
partnership is a couple hundred shekels
cheaper than incorporating your company
and that's what they did now in the end
for a VC to invest they don't invest in
Partnerships so they needed to flip into
a company which cost them a lot of money
had they just had a five second even
call with a lawyer they would have said
no no don't do that you may be saving a
couple hundred check on you know but but
you'll be and this company had to pay a
lot of money to to change into a company
so I think the first thing is really
knowledge
um there are a lot of lawyers out there
a lot of good lawyers out there and and
uh I think don't be afraid to just pick
up the phone and call
oh I think that that's number one that's
very important
um and just being aware of various
issues kind of puts you puts up your
antenna so that you are able man to say
wait maybe that's a problem wait I
remember Ellie said something about that
hold horses at him before I saw anything
for I agree let me just give a call and
make sure that it's okay
for instance sometimes people will
promise a certain percentage you know
don't worry you're going to have two
percent of my company now that's great
but hopefully companies grow and then
you give more and more and more Equity
but if someone was promised two percent
then that two percent may not be diluted
and is always two percent even after the
company has grown so if you had a chance
let's dive into that a little bit okay
let's dive into that a little bit more
because definitely I think a really
important note sure let's do this with
the foundation so percentages numbers
Equity this is something that we're
constantly dealing with okay so I would
say again we started with the most
important thing is the IP you need to
protect that but I think the second most
important asset is is actually the
equity of the company because you only
have a hundred percent
and as as an entrepreneur as a group of
entrepreneurs anything that you give out
will 100 value here and any mistake you
make in the beginning will you're going
to be the one that's gonna be paying for
that mistake so it's very important
especially in the beginning and
especially when you're dealing with
Equity to be very careful and make sure
that things are very very clear because
anytime and you're always looking out as
far as the lawyers and and the advisors
are concerned we want to make sure that
when you get to the exit
that you're not going to have any
stumbling blocks you're not going to
have any obstacles and sometimes people
like to come out of the woodwork and say
oh I saw that you're getting acquired
for X number of hundreds of millions of
dollars by the way I get this and I get
that and usually you'll just throw money
at them to as if to to avoid the
nuisance
anything wow dealt with it correctly
from day one you could even avoid that
so when you were talking about Equity I
think you know promising Equity is fine
again I think we said to promise based
on results not on promises but also you
need to deal in whole numbers
because percentages change all the time
but numbers don't if you have 10 shares
or 100 shares you could say that that
today represents X percent but in the
future it most likely will not because
everyone suffers or enjoys dilution and
people think that dilution is a terrible
thing but if I hold you know 100 of of
the pie and that pie is worth a million
dollars and then someone invests and you
only hold fifty percent but now that 50
that probably is increased not you know
two to 50 million dollars well then what
you hold is actually increased in value
sure
whole numbers you can say and if you're
gonna people want to know what
percentage that is make sure you say
that's what it is today but make sure
that you're not promising that on a
going forward basis
Ryan I mean it sounds like it then you
know this tie-in with the previous items
that we talked about then it sounds like
it it you know the the understanding
from the entrepreneur side that these
that there are technicalities here and
there are important best practices for
how these things work and I assume that
from your position you're coming in and
you're you know you're the you're the
best guidance for the entrepreneur I
mean I'm guessing these are not
necessarily things that an entrepreneur
needs to understand from the get-go but
it's more the practice and the
intentionality of Consulting and having
that understanding that the entrepreneur
may not have all the information and
there are probably
problematic places in everything that
they're doing then a person like you can
come in and guide through that Tunnel
right yeah I mean I would say definitely
I think repeat entrepreneurs make less
mistakes because they've seen it before
they've probably made the mistakes
before and now they know them the second
third or fourth time around not to
repeat those mistakes but because we've
seen hundreds if not thousands of
companies and we've seen a lot not a lot
of mistakes so we know how to avoid
those things and make sure that the
entrepreneur can actually focus on the
business focus on the tech which is
what's really important
uh I remember a conversation I had with
another entrepreneur that was
the afternoon was debating should he go
for the exit that he had on the table or
should he go for an investment to grow
the company that he also had on the
table
to which I you know and I just I kind of
picked you know as long as you have to
ask the right questions I said well what
are you looking you know at the end of
the day we all want to do what's right
we want to do what we enjoy you also
want to make money I said well look how
much money you're going to make out of
this exit
and person so much money I said how much
more do you need
yeah and it was a very nice exit for the
entrepreneur and I said look the
investment's great you know you'll grow
and you'll be a huge company but right
now if you're acquired they'll be part
of the acquiring company which is in and
of itself a big company you'll be part
of that you'll help grow your business
there and you'll get a nice chunk of
change to put on the side which is what
you want if you go for the investment
yes maybe you know you'll be another
Facebook
but maybe you know you won't and there's
no assurances so in the entrepreneur
went home and thought about it and and
came back after we we closed the exit
deal and actually thanked me for that
conversation
because he knew that that was really the
right decision for for him and his
family there are other entrepreneurs who
you know I I just want to grow my
company and be the number one company in
my field and that's fine
again so long as your other partners
agree with that vision
but there's no there's no right or wrong
answer there's a right answer that's for
you I think as long as you consult and
consider all of the relevant parameters
and ramifications of what you decide
then that's fine I'd say what we are is
lawyers are usually again we say trusted
advisors and we give advice and you
could listen to Our advice or you could
not listen to Our advice and we always
go to sleep and we sleep fine you know
any either way we give your advice on
based on our experience and and the
entrepreneur many times listens and
sometimes they don't listen
I would say most of the time when we
give advice I think in the end we're
correct but it it has happened that you
weren't correct based on a business
decision here or there but as long as
I'd say our job is to make sure that the
entrepreneur knows what the risks are
and if the entrepreneur knows what the
risks are then the entrepreneur is the
one who makes the decision yes or no and
you know that's that's why the
entrepreneur holds the equity that's why
the entrepreneurs the entrepreneur and
manager of his or her company
completely
why do you enjoy what you do today so
much
I know it's a very open-ended question
but knowing you look at your day-to-day
what is it that you really get the
biggest kick out of
but I think the best part is really
interaction with people
I think you see a lot of I think it's
the we'll call the tech
um people are are good people so I think
the more you're interacting and it's the
entire ecosystem it's not just the
entrepreneurs it's the investors it's
the advisors and just being day-to-day
with with good people I think that's
that's one of the I think a great part I
think I think it's interesting I think
it's evolving you know if now we're
talking about I remember 20 years ago we
were talking about self-driving cars and
electric cars and you know that was a
dream and now you're seeing it on the
road so it's always nice to see
different things like that some of the
tech is really life-saving and when you
can say look I felt this and helped that
you know I mean my father's a physician
and he's helped more people than I can
count
but you know I won't be saving lives per
se but I could definitely say that I've
helped lives in in doing what I do and
you know at the end of the day I think
it's it's a very interesting feel
I think it's it's always changing and uh
again I think it's the people and the
interesting things that we're working on
I think is really
not only me but I think the rest of the
community is really why we're here
Annie thank you so much this was such an
enjoyable conversation learned a lot uh
some very actionable insights for me as
I'm on to my own journey and I really
want to thank you for the time and the
energy so thank you and stay sick and
stay healthy continue making a positive
impact on entrepreneurs around you and
best of luck thanks for having me